Rob here with a GS news update former
Panamanian dictator Manuel Noriega has
brought Activision a lawsuit over 2012's
call of duty black ops 2 Noriega is
taking legal action against the
publisher for the blatant misuse of
unlawful exploitation and
misappropriation for economic gain of
his image in the popular game Noriega
was the military dictator of Panama from
1983 until 1989 when he was ousted the
80 year old who is now serving a prison
sentence in Panama claims in his lawsuit
in an effort to increase the popularity
and revenue generated by black ops to
activision used without authorization or
consent the image and likeness of Manuel
Noriega in black ops 2 the former
dictator goes on to say that call duty
black ops 2 depicts him as a kidnapper
murderer and enemy of the state Noriega
was convicted of crimes in the USA
including drug trafficking racketeering
and money laundering then he was
extradited to France and charged for
murder before being extradited back to
Panama where he was charged for murder
and human rights abuses he is currently
still in prison Noriega is seeking
damages for the unjust enrichment unfair
business practices and violation of
common law publicity rights in addition
Noriega hopes to collect punitive
damages for lost profits and other
charges according to the lawsuit
gamespot user Rican V has stated in the
comments he has a better case than Lohan
what do you think stay tuned to gamespot
for all of your gaming news
you